for re-election the worst kept political
Secret in Washington is out Joe Biden is
once again running to be U.S president
let's finish this job I know we care the
80 year old made his announcement
through an early morning video
coming exactly four years after he
declared the start of his ultimately
successful 2020 presidential run
[Music]
[Applause]
his first official appearance after the
video release came in front of a labor
group in Washington a key constituency
in that last campaign our economic plan
is working we now have to finish the job
but there's more to do but Biden has
some huge obstacles to overcome he's the
oldest man ever to hold the presidency
and will be 82 when the next election is
held a majority of Voters in a recent
poll had big concerns about his age and
while inflation and costs are coming
down most Americans don't feel better
off and the majority aren't convinced by
Biden's economic plans he's so focused
on governing governing that he doesn't
recognize that you've got to be able to
actually communicate with the American
people that you are in fact working for
them we know that he's been a very
productive president but he and the
people around him simply have not been
the best at actually selling their
message Donald Trump will be his likely
opponent he welcomed Biden to the race
claiming he is the worst president in
American history
setting the scene for what will be a
rerun of the bitter 2020 election
campaign this will be Joe Biden's fourth
run at the White House he believes his
message of protecting fundamental rights
and democracy will once again resonate
with voters the presidential campaign
will get underway in Earnest after the
summer break it will be long it will be
expensive and it will be bitter and for
Joe Biden it will be the last one he
will ever fight Alan Fisher Al Jazeera
at the White House